USC basketball pulled off something that
no school has ever done before if you
don't know already about ju gu Watkins
and Isaiah ker they were the number one
ranked players in the 2023 class and
they were both named nay Smith high
school player of the year and now play
for the same University that's the first
time that two number one recruits have
committed to the same school ever but
that's not where it ends with this Duo
who committed the USC within less than
24 hours of each other because they're
special on and off the court ju guu and
La native is a two-time gold medalist
and was named Gatorade player of the
year she's also the first female athlete
to sign with clutch which led to her
being a part of Nike's nil class and
even get her own electric Mercedes as
part of a sponsorship deal now with
Isaiah he's a play maker and the bucket
he's the first point guard to be ranked
number one in his class since K
hunningham in 2020 the only freshman on
the Pack 12 preseason All-American first
team and is a projected lottery pick in
the 2024 draft let's just say